people want a single stable currency
that they can price globally stable
coins would be a huge positive and i
think that would be a positive for the
us dollar the significant question is
what what is the implications of what's
happening in stable coins
traditional and decentralized finance
are two different worlds
one is punching numbers in a manhattan
skyscraper and the other is coding a new
blockchain from home stablecoins are
looking to be the bridge between the two
industries so a stablecoin is a coin
that is pegged one for one with the
dollar and the way we ensure that that
coin is actually keeps that peg that one
for one with the dollar is that
they are a custodian for actual fiat
currency stable coins are are tokens
that track the u.s dollar typically so i
get to say what they really are they're
crypto dollars
crypto dollars are akin to euro dollars
mid euro dollars track to us dollar and
banks outside the u.s and what this lets
you do is it lets you interact with the
d5 ecosystem using digital assets that
don't have any volatility with respect
to the dollar for if you were to hold
just bitcoin and that's going to rise
and fall with the price of bitcoin as
brett mentioned a stablecoin is a
cryptocurrency designed to have a
relatively stable price
this means it can be backed by fiat a
commodity other cryptos or even
algorithmically cryptocurrency is a
digital currency which is built on a
blockchain a blockchain is a database
record that guarantees the fidelity and
security of transactions and all of this
generally exists under the umbrella of
decentralized finance or d5 for short
it's the emerging financial system
separate from wall street to me
this is indicative of
the revolution of cryptos
number one fact is when you sort by
volume in
coinmarketcap.com the number one trade
is
crypto on the planet is tether
people don't a lot of people don't
understand that yet the world has gone
for the dollar organically through
cryptos which shows the significance of
this our free market capitalism i
frankly think that stable coins
represent a compelling way to be able to
uh
deliver sort of
a
really modernized asset transfer system
and and and markets structure while
still using uh a one to one dollar
backed asset you know as uh the reserve
currency and so i think that's something
which you know i think is of strategic
importance to the united states if we
sort of stifle crypto if intellectual
property for crypto moves overseas if we
don't allow stable coins to exist in the
us and that's going to move somewhere
else maybe it moves to euro maybe it
moves to yen maybe it moves to chinese
iran these are all concerns that we
should have as americans and making sure
that
we take that first place when it comes
to crypto this adds pressure on u.s
regulators like sec chair gary gensler
to create guard rails on decentralized
financial markets without hurting
sentiment towards the us dollar
one thing to note is that i think we are
going to see some stable coin
legislation move
certainly some of the recommendations
from the president's working group
report on financial markets on stable
coins was to recommend that there is
some legislative framework that is
passed and to be honest with you i think
we're seeing bipartisan support on
stable coin legislation moving and that
to me is the low-hanging fruit in
congress so i think we're going to start
with stable coins and then potentially
move on to some other topics that will
have
maybe broader implications for all of
crypto and all of the crypto markets but
i think we're going to start with stable
coins
stablecoin legislation will be a major
moment for cryptocurrency adoption into
the global economic system
whether or not investors continue to
favor the united states dollar or
another currency is yet to be seen
people want a single stable currency
that they can price globally as opposed
to having these fragmented markets just
naturally how it's developed so just
empirically speaking the us dollar
really is it
even though a stablecoin might sound
like a sure thing it's a new technology
in a world figuring out use cases and
its own regulation and that likely means
volatility before it's figured out on
all sides
[Music]
you